jimmy
you're okay yeah why
some of my favorite movies are 70s crime
dramas and i've always loved the genre
and loved those movies even though they
are not particularly interested
in protagonists that represent me
this is 200 grand cal will manage how
the money is spent but you hold on to it
just as the action gets going the man
always kicks
his wife his girlfriend out of the movie
and julia's sort of main
question was what happens if we stay
with her it was a different take on
motherhood and womanhood than i had seen
before in this space
in one of those classic mob movies my
character would be
a porn whereas in i'm your woman you see
these characters that
kind of exist on the outside and they
become the leads you know and so we see
it from their perspective
all eddie said is he wouldn't be home
tonight i don't know what's going on or
who you are
or why any of this is happening when we
first meet jean
we have a picture of a woman who is
fairly comfortable
in her life action and then the whole
world comes in
in the guise of harry this baby she
gonna say something
who's that because of crimes that her
husband commits
is forced out of her life with her child
jeanne
is kind of lost very dependent and then
because of this thing she finds out
about her husband
learns how to be independent learns how
to be a mom learns how to be her own
woman
and so the uncertainty and the pitfalls
and the dangers of
the crime world felt like an interesting
place to put a woman who is also
struggling with what it means to be
a parent and a mother and it was really
fun to do that
through classic set pieces from 70s
crime dramas
someone's following us
i find that with the locations where
we're going to lend themselves very well
to our film
pittsburgh has this old school feel and
it can be
so many things we need it to be we have
a cabin
that's in a very rustic looking place
and then it can be a city for when we
need to do a scene that's in a nightclub
sort of in a city environment we can
find that easily
hello there gorgeous one
no the nightclub sequence was probably
the hardest
thing to shoot the sequence was written
very specifically with this nightclub in
this back hallway and this other room so
like we had all that and knew that we
needed
that shape when we were on our first
location scout
we found that main nightclub space that
has that incredible balcony that jean is
on and that stage
but the space didn't have all of the
elements
oriented exactly as we needed them and
that place happened to have like an
upstairs room that we were like okay
this could work as a back room
then there was a basement where we could
build the hallway
and so we had to shot list the entire
sequence before we could say yes to the
location
to make sure that we could make that
idea of where those different spaces
were in the sequence
adhere to the way they were written in
the script and we stuck to that shot
list
exactly and the sequence is cut pretty
much exactly as we had
initially shot listed it when we first
found the space why didn't you tell me
eddie would keep me in the dark told me
it was to protect me just like you just
like cal but i don't believe it anymore
is it any of this real or are you just
like the rest of them
terry and gene have decided to
stop trusting the men to take care of
things and take matters into their own
hands
and this is a club that eddie probably
spent a lot of time in
but always kept gene away from it jean's
never been here he was hiding this
whole other life from her and so now
she's seeing what this world is really
like
with her own eyes and it is full of lies
and danger and
this whole sequence was really
challenging to shoot for so many reasons
not the least of which is that
anytime you're doing stunt work with
your lead actors
and a whole bunch of background actors
you know you just have to be
incredibly vigilant and incredibly
patient you can't rush you have to take
your time with things you have to get
things right
the reason we wanted to put gene in a
phone booth is because we just wanted to
show the visual metaphor of this box
that she's been put in by
the men in her life and the people in
her life and how this is the moment that
she
finally decides instead of watching
everything happen from the box you know
she's gonna run out into it herself
this is one take and this is rachel
and a whole bunch of background actors
we rehearsed extensively with our stunt
people
and bryce our dp is operating the camera
here
and it's pretty extraordinary to me the
dance that bryce and rachel do
through the sea of background actors it
feels to me like the visual metaphor of
all of the chaos and the turmoil and
danger that gene is going through she's
just like hurtled
into this sea of bodies trying to find
her way out
there is some visual effects work in the
shot but there's not much
our art department designed that fox den
sign and i think it looks incredible
uh but a lot of that neon in the deep
background was all there
it's incredible how much of pittsburgh
feels like the 1970s
i think the thing that i'm most proud of
in rachel's performance is that she
makes this
completely ordinary everyday suburban
housewife
this woman who you just want to know
everything about
and who you go on this journey with it
was a really
amazing experience to be able to work on
this film
as not only an actor but a producer with
two of them she was incredible i don't
know how she wears so many hats but she
handled it really beautifully
you're all right
i'm your woman felt so refreshing we're
making a film in the 1970s
and focusing on having a female lead it
felt like a brand new perspective
it's directed and written by a woman
centring a woman
and i love that this movie took pieces
of those movies that i recognized and
was familiar with
but took it in a completely new
direction
this can all be over
you